c'est vrai je vends en tant que ça c'est
l'histoire d'une classe de cm2 de
l'école les quarante arpents qui part à
la rencontre d'un compteur et qui décide
avec leur maîtresse de raconter des
contes bretons et felipe c'est une
histoire d'une petite fille qui
rencontre une feuille qu'il aide pour
réaliser ses voeux et a quitté sa
méchante belle-mère à ce qui me plaît
plus quand je suis sur scène c'est
pouvoir voir m'exprimer au décès est en
fait moi ce qui me plaît surtout c'est
que ça m'entraîne à surmonter mes peurs
fui et korrigans les petites créatures
légendaires de bretagne envahissent la
médiathèque
antoine de saint-exupéry à voisins le
bretonneux les élèves s'imprègne des
textes et prennent possession de la
scène j'ai c'est que ça vienne d'eux
déjà des seuils de le jeu du regard
d'être capable de main de regarder son
public parce que là c'est vraiment quand
on est les compteurs on s'adresse
vraiment un public directement alors
qu'un acteur peut s'adresser un comédien
avec qui joue là on est tout seul aulas
c'est un peu différent ce que par
moments ils sont deux donc c'est un peu
entre les deux mais voilà puis j'essaie
de leur faire sentir les émotions des
scènes pour ccm de la première
difficulté de comprendre et de
s'approprier les comptes souvent
complexes les contes bretons cetc
des comptes qui sont un peu compliqué
parfois très moralisateur pour les
enfants c'était pas toujours simple de
les comprendre qu'il a fallu au départ
décortiquer ces textes afin qu'ils les
comprennent bien pour pouvoir ensuite
les restituer avec leur propre langage
dans le cadre de la 19ème édition de la
fête du conte des élèves de cm2 se
produiront le 29 janvier à 11 heures sur
la scène de la salle de la tour